how does an east tennessee guy
who's got you have to have some swagger
to become a 26 year old real estate
mogul and then falls off and then
is immediately into hustling again i
gotta feed this family yeah i have a
choice
how in the world does that guy
um summon the humility to go to a
therapist therapist was not a thing back
then
that was you i mean no it was no
there wasn't a marriage therapist on
every corner like there is now no and
uh but you know
basically we're going we i looked at it
like going to class
okay like i learned some new tools like
i don't know how to do this
so i need somebody to teach me how to do
this yeah that's a special level of
humility dave
well i didn't know how to do it i mean
it wasn't it was it was
it was not i guess it was not like i
think i know how but i'm going to be
humble no it wasn't it was like
i don't know what the crap i'm doing
here i mean i didn't know how to be
married
and i certainly didn't know how to be
married but from a christian perspective
and so i'm studying scriptures and
you know we're going to christian
marriage retreats
and christian marriage weekends and
seminars and
this stuff and so i'm learning the
scriptural concepts of this
and and you know i'm starting to learn
how to apply them and
you know but but uh uh
you know and i'm dying and being reborn
uh literally uh in so many facets of my
life but certainly spiritually
uh in that process and so i it really
wasn't it was more like
uh and it wasn't really like this
desperate thing but it was i
don't know how to fix this and i don't
have and the manual i've got
is confusing so i need somebody to guide
me through the manual
and it was just for me it was like a
practical thing if it makes any sense
but
yeah and i didn't go to fix her because
i did that i i
i'll give myself a little credit yeah i
didn't go i'm taking you to marriage
counseling to straighten you out
because i was well aware that the
majority of it was me and i also
knew enough about trauma i wouldn't have
called it that in those days but i you
know i studied enough enough psych in
school and that kind of stuff to
get the idea that we've been through
hell and it affected both of us
right and so we were damaged goods
trying to
two damaged people i mean my insecurity
was magnified off the roof because i'd
lost all confidence
and competence as if i had any and her
uh
her insecurity turned into just sheer
terror she's afraid every move i was
going to make was going to put us in the
street
yeah uh and rightly so it had you know
so you know we had to work through some
did you have a family
map for that or were you out in the
woods on this we were out in the woods i
mean we had
church family but i mean you you didn't
have like a
um a mom or dad that went through stuff
and you saw them treat each other this
way
or my answer my parents are you know her
parents and my parents stayed married
their whole lives
they were there you know but that's all
we knew we didn't know how they did it
right yeah you know
uh and we knew and we knew it was messy
of course how you do it because it is
always messy right
uh if you think it's not messy you're
lying yeah that's right so um
you know or you haven't been married
long um or whatever a lady come up said
had never had a fight with my husband in
35 years and i said that's because
you're a liar right you know it's like
you know the book clients she does he
does drugs people stuff say in book
lines right
but um but yeah that and so that's all
in that
pretext and really that hasn't changed
because like you know i start running a
business and i'm going
i don't know what i'm doing so i got to
get you know john maxwell in my corner i
got to get
henry cloud in my corner i got to get
and i didn't even know these men i
started reading their stuff they become
friends later but
because but but they yeah i had to have
a guide
to lead me through the forest on these
different things that i didn't know
and i'm still looking i i i don't look
for a singular mentor i don't believe in
that these i need someone to be my
mentor
thing i don't do this stuff but um but i
do i do look at a guy and go hey he's
got a good marriage okay dude what are
you doing
or that guy's look at his kids turned
out how'd you do that you know
because i'm afraid to kill mine so
how do you let them live and they turn
out you know it does
sound so april speak we'll see like i
need to learn how to
how to fix this vacuum that guy knows
how i'm going to call that guy
that's a that's an increase it's always
been rare and it's an increasingly rare
earth thing because now we've got these
little
boxes on our phones that tell us that we
know everything we can just google it
right well yeah
but there's not a lot of people in it it
is a type of humility but it's not this
but what happened was i have the benefit
of being humiliated
by being this crushing experience going
through losing everything
and so there was nothing left
uh that said dave knew anything right
and so it was really easy to go
i don't know how to do that because
obviously i don't want to do anything
you know kind of thing
so you know and so starting from that
point but that kid that was
uh arrogant little you know
25 year old 24 year old whatever would
not have gone to counseling because he
would not have been wrong about anything
okay so when i've made
stupid mistakes says stupid things we we
had a joint conference a zoom conference
with my kids with hank school today
and after the meeting i told sheila hey
i want to join that zoom and she just
looked at me with that one pause and i
said i won't embarrass us
and so we had the zoo meeting and i
texted her after did i embarrass this
and she wrote no and that that nope and
i was like okay good
um you can go home tonight i'm good yes
i can sleep inside so when we do
dumb things or stupid things i wear my
shame right i i have to deal with me
i've got it and i'm
my tendency is like you i need to
surround myself by people who know how
to do things i don't know how to do
and i love that's one of my favorite
things about being alive
but my wife i've learned over the years
where's it too
in a different way how did to the best
of you understand
how was sharon walking through this
as someone who'd hitched her wagon to a
smooth talking
yeah multi-millionaire then then wasn't
yeah um
i mean her first thing she would tell
you was that she was terrified
that the experience terrified her and so
we had to put um marriage counseling did
this and common sense did this too we
had to put rules in our life
that keep me from doing something
without her
agreement that's gonna terrify her
and so uh for instance we don't spend
over five hundred dollars either one of
us without first talking about it
to this day we do live on a budget yeah
yeah i'm worth hundreds of millions of
dollars and i don't spend over 500
without talking to my wife i never go
and just buy something
now we these days with the zeros we live
with we
are less and less concerned about it you
know if she wants to buy a
purse that costs more than it should i'm
no big deal because that means i get
another gun but yeah
so a little trade-off here but uh you
know but it's not uh
so it's not like you know we're but in
the old days it was like
here we go again it was like you're
scamming and scheming again that's what
she would say
and so i don't know if that gives you
insight into her mindset or not
i don't think sh i you would have to ask
her to be sure but i
didn't read her as shame
that was me but she didn't cause it
she just was hitched to it yeah you know
now she was like at a family reunion
with her
family the fact that we were bankrupt
now that she might have felt shame with
that but even with our friends and stuff
she's like well he's just an idiot you
know
i mean i mean maybe not exactly that not
that raw but i mean she's just like
she'll call it she jiggles it like it is
she didn't feel like she caused it
because she didn't
okay and so uh but but except to the
extent that she didn't speak up
and uh years later she found her voice
and it works real well now
but um but she didn't speak up she was
just kind of the southern belt whatever
you want to do honey
and then later on she go but i knew it
wasn't gonna work and i'm like well why
don't you say anything you're
dead gum genius until after the fact but
um so we just don't do stuff but when
but we're both
in agreement and uh we don't make
large philanthropic gifts we do a lot of
giving to ministry through our family
foundation
it's all structured with family all
speaks into it our kids speak into it
sharon and i are in agreement and if one
of my buddies calls up that's got a
ministry and goes hey i need ten
thousand dollars for this if there's
even if i know there's room in the
budget i
email sharon and denise my daughter's
the director of the foundation i'm going
so-and-so's wanting ten thousand dollars
i think we've got in the budget i think
we ought to do it what do y'all think
now i easily can make that decision i
make hundreds of thousands of
decisions around the company every day
without talking to
them i run it through the leadership
team here but
uh but the accountability back to that
keeps me from walking up on thin ice
that activates her old scars
her old wounds and would you for both of
you are they still there somewhere
oh yeah yeah there i mean will be the
rest of our lives
less and less the more and more padding
you had over them
and the more distance you have the more
healed they are uh
i mean if you'd ask us two years later
or five years later it felt
a lot different yeah for both of us um
and uh you know i've worked past that
shame and worked past that uh the
insecurity
and the humiliation that i put myself
through
by owning it but also by not doing it
anymore and i'm not that guy anymore
right so i'm not that i'm not you know
i'm i'm
i'm a better dad i'm a better husband
i'm a better
i'm not not arrived don't get me wrong
i'm a better leader
than i was when i started and so uh that
allows me to give myself grace